we're now going into chapter four of
Kierkegaard's philosophical fragments
and this chapter is actually titled the
case of the contemporary disciple so
what it might give you the impression
that we're talking about is contemporary
in the sense of right now or at least
right now in Kierkegaard's time the
disciple perhaps the the Christian of
what he called Chris and um in the you
know mid-1800s or if you're thinking
back to the fact you know he's talking
about Christ as being the person who the
disciple is the disciple loved in this
this case maybe what he has in mind is
really those people who were immediately
involved with with Christ around the
years say 32 33 34 ad or those who knew
him you know a little bit earlier or
something like that as it turns out
that's not actually in the full sense
what he means he's going to be using the
contemporary disciple of the time of
Christ as sort of a launching pad but
not everybody who at that time might
have had the the title of being a
disciple would actually fit
Kierkegaard's profile of what counts as
discipleship in in this sense and he's
beginning from a place that we've seen
now several times in the course of this
the distinction between a sort of
religious point of view of Education and
the Socratic point of view and then
other points of view of Education so
let's begin
antha the start of this chapter he says
the God has thus made his appearance as
teacher for we now resume our story in
has assumed the form of a servant this
is so that the God could overcome the
unlike Narae all reasoning human being
and the the God to send another in his
place one high in his confidence could
not satisfy him you know like a prophet
for example just as it could not satisfy
the noble kyng descent instead even the
most trusted man is king
he's referring back to this this story
about the noble king who loves the
beautiful maiden and through his love
you know has to enter into this
relationship this paradoxical
relationship with her so a then he says
but the god he had also another reason
this is a very important point for
between man and man the Socratic
relationship is the highest and the
truest so you know very often
Kierkegaard has taken as if he's just
disparaging philosophy he's saying that
you know Hegelian ism or you know Plato
and sock you know Socrates point of view
is no good really what he's saying is no
as a matter of fact you can
differentiate within the you know purely
human or natural realm between levels of
quality levels of truth and the highest
that you can get to is this level of the
Socratic this is the best that has been
attained and mankind discovered it back
in you know ancient Greece you know I
don't think Kierkegaard himself would
have a problem with saying yeah you
could find this in other other locations
as well because the whole point about
the Socratic is that it's not dependent
solely on the person who is the teacher
the teacher is showing the student what
is already in the student so there's a
relationship of identity between the
teacher and the learner that the learner
has to actually come to realize and then
thereby essentially take the place of
the teacher and this fits in very well
with with Plato's understanding of
knowledge as being able to teach those
who truly possess knowledge can impart
that knowledge to a learner so Turkey
guard is saying something very important
here between man and man the Socratic
relationship is the highest and the
trust if the God had not come himself
all the relations would have remained on
the Socratic level and that wouldn't
have been terrible but something would
have been lacking something
than missing and remember to going all
the way back to you know chapter 1 and
chapter 2 from the socratic level it
can't even be adequately conceptualized
what is missing what has been left out
so says the god servant form was not a
mere disguise but as actual it is not a
pair of static body but an actual body
and from the hour that in the omnipotent
purpose of his am nipa tenth of the God
became a servant he has so to speak in
prison himself in his resolve and is now
bound to go on whether it pleases him or
no and what he's exploring here again
I've said this a number of times is he's
doing a philosophical interpretation of
theological or religious doctrines
dogmas truths however you want to to put
it so there's there's something that's
very important here that he that he's
talking about though he says well the
God will not be able to send anyone in
his place he can't indeed send someone
before him true aroused alert his
attention the God's presence is not
accidental in relation to his teaching
but essential the God's presence in
human form I in the humble form of a
servant is itself the teaching so that's
something very important to linger over
it's not just the teacher coming and
then imparting some sort of doctrine to
the student or you know the Socratic way
getting the student to realize that he
has the doctrine in him and he's really
you know identical that the teacher or
anything like that it is the very
significant act of coming and taking the
form of weakness vulnerability of
servitude on the part of the teacher the
reaching out to the disciple this is
what it means for the person to actually
encounter love God has been
conceptualized in many different ways in
one of the things that that you know you
is striking about the Gospels
particularly the Gospel of John is is
this notion that God is in fact you
might say love and Carnot there we're
also sort of bringing in letters of love
John as well but now notice this is not
Scripture depending he's trying to
develop this out of thinking out this
problematic so he says the God did not
assume the form of a servant to make a
mockery of men so he doesn't pass
through the world in such a manner that
no single human being becomes aware of
his presence he will therefore give some
sort of sign though every understanding
resting upon accommodation is
essentially with a value for one who
does not receive the condition and care
guarantee means this word condition a
number of different times and we're
going to have to figure out what that
actually means you notice I don't have
that on this chart that's going to be
something that's taking place in between
and we'll see what it what it actually
is he says such a sign when given is as
capable of repelling the learner as of
drawing him near so it's not something
that reason human reason would say oh
yeah there you go now I understand
everything perfect just what I wanted
and here's here's a good spot to linger
for just a moment when you think about
the debates that people get into about
religion quite often people who are on
the side saying you know religion is all
bunk and you know God is a figment of
your imagination or any of those sorts
of things
well frequently say things like ah you
know just give me something that would
be absolutely convinced me and a lot of
times religious people fall into the
trap of thinking I've got a great
knock-down drag-out argument that's
going to be irrefutable for them well
you know somebody like Kierkegaard would
say you know that's not going to work
that's not the way things actually took
place and in fact if the learner or the
disciple is in error and if their error
is the very first thing like we saw in
the last couple of chapters that the
teacher teaches the disciple the fact
of their own error then it's not going
to be the case that you could come up
with some sort of argument that would
convince everybody necessarily that
would compel them rather you can provide
signs and signs require interpretation
so let's skip on ahead a little bit
so I'm actually skipping over quite a
bit of material Oregon is making some
comparisons between love and the
relationship between the teacher and the
disciple they said he says the question
is whether a human being may venture to
express the same idea that God would be
sort of like a Footloose wanderer just
seeking the love of the disciple for
otherwise the God does not realized the
essential elements of a human life we
answered in the affirmative a man may so
venture if he has the needed strength he
can so lose himself in the service of
the Spirit that it never occurs to him
to take care for me to drink if he is
certain that want will not distract him
that distress will not confound him the
structure of his life and teach him to
rue that he did not master the first
simple things before he presumed to
understand more that he may indeed
venture and his greatness will be more
glorious in the serene security of the
lilies of the field so what he's
addressing here is well why didn't God
you know why didn't God just show up
this like every man and get married and
have children and then like you know say
oh yeah I totally understand the human
condition there is still a relationship
of unlike 'no stew a certain extent
between the the teacher showing up in
the historical Christianity and some of
the new learners now I start saying some
some pretty funny things here and he
says this lofty absorption in his
mission will of itself suffice to
attract the attention of the multitude
and you know what happens well with
spiritual teachers they do attract a
multitude people come to them and now
the question is this is the question
that you're going to be asking are those
people all disciples
in the same way are they all in this
relationship that we sort of sketched
down here which is a you might say
ontological or metaphysical relationship
as well as being you know one between
persons so he says the latter meaning
the multitude will in all probability
come from the humbler walks of life for
the wise and the learned will presumably
wish to propose kept Isha's questions to
the teacher invite him to colloquial or
subject him to an examination upon which
they will assure him a permanent
position and a secure livelihood and you
know this makes sense the ordinary
people when something new comes on the
scene they don't stand on ceremony they
come out of hallway what what is this
what is this and they tend to get pretty
excited their excitement can you know
wane and wax rather unpredictably the
more learning people the people who have
a stake the people who have prestige
they the people who have established
positions they come out and they try to
frame things in terms of those those
established positions so if something
new comes on the scene they have to or
you know even if it's Socrates coming on
the scene they have to figure out where
do you fit in in relation to me and what
I what I'm used to thinking in terms of
so he says let us not picture the God
going about in the city of his
appearance to make his teaching known as
the sole necessity of his life it is his
meat and drink teaching is his labor and
caring for the learner is his rest from
labor beautiful expression their
teaching is his labor and caring for the
learner is his rest from labor he has no
friends were kindred but the learner is
his brother and sister so there's this
relationship that's established there
that's a intimate familiar and yet
social relationship it may readily it
may readily be understood that a web of
rumor will soon be woven catching the
curious multitude in its snare wherever
the teacher appears the crowd gathers
curious to see curious to hear eager to
tell others that they have seen and
heard him now Kierkegaard asks at this
point is this curious multitude
the learner is this curious multitude in
this relationship this is by no means so
it's not just associating oneself with
this religious figure that makes a
person the learner or places oneself in
according to Kierkegaard the
relationship of faith he says what if
one of the authorized teachers of this
cities thought about secretly and you
think about you know some of the scribes
and Pharisees and even nickim Adiemus
coming coming in the middle of the night
all right in order to try it strength
with him an argument is here the learner
he might have a better better claim to
being called the learner no it says by
no means if this teacher are that
multitude learn anything here's a
brilliant thing if this teacher this
multitude learn anything it's taking
place in a Socratic sense so something
that appears on the surface religious is
not really religious and you get the
idea that the Kierkegaard would be quite
willing to say that what was going on
say in the wisdom literature of the
Bible or what was going on in the you
know the development of the Pharisaic
tradition which leads to rabbinical
Judaism is really in many ways something
that's more Socratic than than religious
in the sense that Kierkegaard is is
exploring now that's something that we
don't have the time to really go into
detail about here but it's worth
meditating upon how much of the time are
we are we confused by seeing some
religious you know exterior and saying
oh the relationship that these people
have must be religious it must be a
matter of faith when perhaps really the
relationship is a Socratic one and
remember a Socratic relationship is not
that by itself it's just not this
it's the best that man to man human
being to human being rational
you know practical reason err - it's a
practical reason er can work out
together in community so he says the
gods appearance has now become the news
of the day in the marketplace in the
homes of the people in the
council-chamber of the rule rulers
palace it gives occasion for much
foolish and idle talk perhaps also for
some earnest reflection but for the
learner the news of the day is not an
occasion for something else not even an
occasion for the acquirement of the
Socratic simplicity of a deeper and
fuller self-knowledge for the learner it
is the eternal the beginning of eternity
both the Socratic and the religious are
focused on the eternal and that's
something really important from from an
existential point of view at least
Kierkegaard's version of existentialism
is not simply losing oneself in the
everyday in the shifting mundane details
even though they do exist it's not what
he calls historical existence right that
that has all of the importance or
ontological density and depth within
itself it's the eternal and the
historical matters in so far at least as
far as a religious concern in that the
eternal in the historical come in to
come into confluence with each other
it's not the historical by itself that
for a Kierkegaard Kierkegaard II an
existentialist has ontological
importance it's how the eternal enters
in and these are two different
relationships - and in them - the
eternal
so he says
the God itself given gives this
condition the condition of the moment
the moment is really decisive for an
eternity unless the God grant the
condition which makes it possible to
understand this
how can it be suppose that the learner
will be able to discover it but that the
God himself gives us condition has been
shown about to be a consequence of the
moment if you accept that the moment has
taken place that something has happened
where eternity and time meet together
and flood each other
rupture into each other then you know
you can derive philosophically and
that's what he's done in the previous
chapters that you have to have this sort
of structure of a teacher in relation to
the disciple the teacher is God and the
paradox the disciple is the human
rational person who is also in error and
remember we talked about the possibility
of an understanding if it's an unhappy
understanding that it's a fence that's
what we talked about in the last video
installments of this but if it's a happy
understanding that is the happy passion
of what we call faith Kierkegaard is
gonna tell us quite a bit about this so
he says here at the outset let us take
let us take care to make it clear that
the question of a historical point of
departure arises even for a contemporary
disciple but we're not careful here
we'll meet with an insuperable
difficulty later when we come to deal
with the case of the disciple who we
called the disciple at second hand
that's in Chapter five which is coming
up a little bit later
the contemporary disciple the disciple
who's there with the teacher gets an
historical point of departure for his
eternal consciousness as well as any
other later disciple for he is
contemporary with precisely that
historical phenomenon which were dude
which refuses to be reduced to a moment
of merely occasional significance but
proposes to interest him in another
sense than the merely historical
presenting itself to him as a condition
for his eternal
yes so what is kicker you're talking
about here again the analogy he's not
making this analogy here but the analogy
to love may be may be quite useful there
are moments in time not moments you know
like seconds minutes that sort of thing
there there are times let's say where
the the environment that we're in the
context the what triggered is calling
the historical the the article what
would it is that were engaged with that
we perceive that engages us where we
feel like there's a greater significance
not just a greater significance like
this coffee is better than other coffee
you know greater in the Adsense but
greater in a whole different scale but
it might be you know silly to like do
the ascending thing maybe it has to do
with depth or fullness or richness or
complexity we sense you know for
instance when you fall in love with
somebody and you're just dying to know
about them and understand them and
you're spending all this time together
the world appears to you in a different
way the details of your life think about
a kiss for example when a kiss this
touching of lips and perhaps some other
things as well can have so much
significance that you would write a poem
about it afterwards just to try to
capture some of what went into it in the
anticipation and in the after a fact and
and all of this sort of stuff you know
the confusion it breeds and your soul
all those sorts of things you know if
that takes place and perhaps for some
people it never has compare that against
a peck on the cheek to somebody you know
that you give in greeting they're like
rules apart right
that's what Kierkegaard is talking about
here
the disciple perceives in this
historical milieu this historical moment
not just something that transcends in
importance in a sort of quantifiable way
or even just in terms of levels of
quality but in an absolute way the the
other historical things that they're
engaged with so he says here we go
it proposes to interest him in another
sense than the merely historical
presenting it itself to him as a
condition for his eternal happiness
if this is not so the teacher is not the
God but only a Socrates and if he does
not conduct himself like a Socrates he's
not even a Socrates but how does the
learner come to realize an understanding
with his paradise how does this take
place we do not ask that he understand
the paradox but only that this is the
paradox it comes to pass when reason and
the paradox encounter each other happily
in the decisive moment when the reason
hears we go there we go reason sets
itself aside remember last discussion
that we had reason sets itself aside
that doesn't mean that it destroys
itself that it says okay I'm no longer
gonna think or anything like that
but it says there's something greater
than me I need to learn from this in the
paradox the stove's itself is a gift
that a reason cannot master compel and
necessitate it does give itself though
and it's gift is fruitful so he says the
third entity in which this union is
realized for it's not realized in the
reason because it's set aside and it's
not satisfied it's not realizing the
paradox which bestows itself it is
realized in something the third thing is
faith he says this is the happy passion
to which we will now assign a name
though it is not the name so much that
matters we will call this passion faith
this then must be the condition of all
this must be the condition of which we
have spoken which the paradox
contributes
so although I haven't put this on here
yeah paradox in the paradox in bestowing
itself to reason his in fact bestowing
faith upon the disciple a faith and here
we have to ask a question that
Kierkegaard is really not answering for
us but I think it's very important how
does that faith exist with reason does
it exist in sort of juxtaposition to it
so here reason ends here faith begins
and vice-versa where do they say fuse
and then fuse each other are they
completely distinct from each other do
they modify each other do they affect
each other within the believer in any
way those are worth considering
so he says let us not forget that if the
paradox does not grant this condition
the only way you could get it the
learner would have to be in possession
of it but if the learner is in
possession of this condition he already
is the truth and the moment is merely
the moment of occasion then we have the
Socratic relation so like it says the
contemporary learner finds it easy
enough to acquire adequate historical
information why because their
johnny-on-the-spot there on the ground
they know about this teacher let us not
forget that with respect to the teachers
birth he will be in the same position of
this is the disciple at second hand so
somebody in 100 AD or 200 AD or you know
in the third millennium or whenever you
want if we which wish to urge an
absolute historical precision there will
only be one human being who is fully
informed namely the woman of whom he
permitted himself to be more so the
contemporary disciples placed in a kind
of interesting position and he says he
says let's imagine some some people
imagine a contemporary who reduced his
hours of sleep to a minimum so he's like
you know the electric eye following this
guy around all the time
so that he might follow this teacher
about attending and more closely than
the pilot fish the shark suppose them to
keep a hundred spies in his service to
watch over the teacher everywhere
conferring with them every evening in
order to obtain a description of the
teachers movements exactly that my
nudists detail accounted for
he said where he'd been each over the
day because the zeal let him to attach
importance to the least trifle would
such a contemporary be the disciple
again your God says by no means that's
not what this consists then it's not
knowing everything about the teacher
even though the teacher is part of what
is what is being taught knowing all
these details that that consists in in
discipleship or faith
he says if every suppose another
contemporary who concerned himself
solely with the doctrine which this
teacher was want on occasion to expound
if every word of instruction that fell
from his lips seemed more important to
him than his daily bread if he kept a
hundred assistants watching for every
syllable so that nothing should be lost
if he conferred with them carefully each
evening in order to obtain a
presentation of the doctrine that should
have the highest possible reliability
would he honest account be the disciple
there's time that a lot of theologians
there isn't he thank your God says by no
means that's not what it means to
actually be the disciple either it's not
to memorize chapter and verse it's not
to be able to roll the things out like
that there's something else that's
involved so he says suppose a
contemporary had been living abroad
returned at a time when the teacher had
only a day or two to live if engagements
had prevented him from going to see the
teacher so he was brought into touch
with him only at the last moment when he
was about to yield his spirit with his
historical ignorant prevent him from
becoming the disciple provided the
moment became for him decisive for
eternity and he says let's compare this
guy to the other two cases that we've
looked at for the first contemporary the
life of the teacher was merely him an
historical event he's not treating him
as the teacher not in the sense that
we're talking about here for the second
the teacher served as an occasion by
which he came to an understanding of
himself and he will be able to forget
the teacher just like if you actually
understand everything that Socrates he
has to teach you you can forget Socrates
or Plato or you know and you just have
it in yourself and Socrates would say
good for you
right he has over against an eternal
understanding of oneself any knowledge
about the teacher becomes accidental and
historical only a mere matter of memory
as long as Kierkegaard says the eternal
and historical are external to each
other historical is merely an occasion
what about this other guy he is the
contemporary disciple so he says if the
entire situation is non Socratic that is
the teacher is is giving something more
than Socrates could give to the students
remember Socrates says I can't actually
give you anything all I can do is like
you know remove obstacles from your way
I can I can provoke you the disciple
will all all to the teacher which is
quite impossible in relation to the
Socrates it's a Socrates this
relationship of owing all to the teacher
cannot be expressed in terms of
Romancing a trumpet trumpeting but only
in that happy passion to call faith
whose object is the paradox so faith for
Kierkegaard involves the consciousness
of owing all including understanding of
one's air perhaps even realizing that
the reason that one has as well as the
faith that one has is actually being
bestowed upon one from from the teacher
as well so he says the paradox unites
the contradictory and is the historical
made eternal and the eternal made
historical everyone who understands the
paradox differently may keep the honor
of having explained it so you know he's
saying if you want to understand the
paradox differently that's fine I'm
going to explain it this way so he says
it's easy to see though it scarcely
needs to be pointed out since it's
involved in the fact that the reason is
set aside faith is not a form of
knowledge Kierkegaard says for all
knowledge is either knowledge of the
eternal excluding the temporal and
historical isn't different which is in
the Socratic relation you know learn the
forms
learn what you have in common with
everybody else or it is pure historical
knowledge things of you know the
contingent Caesar cross the Rubicon at
this this place or didn't do that or
this movie is playing right now or I am
6 foot 3 or you know things along those
lines he says that's what knowledge is
no knowledge can here for its object the
absurdity that the Eternity the attorney
that eternity is the historical so
Kierkegaard is saying that faith is not
a form of knowledge and in a sense it is
beyond or it transcends knowledge does
that mean that now we you know rational
thought is completely gone well if it if
it did and I don't think he'd be writing
anything what do you so he says what
else can we say about faith the object
of faith is not the teaching you
probably should say here not the
teaching alone because the teaching does
play some role right but let's go with
this so he says the object of faith is
not the teaching but the teacher that's
what faith is connecting one to the
teacher the person it's a personal
relation so faith can't merely be a
substitute for knowledge
it can't be a I'm gonna believe in
things even though they're completely
crazy and I have no basis for believing
in them but I'm gonna like make myself
do it
he says that's not the way it works and
he also goes on to clarify his voice
says faith is not an act of will for all
human volition has its capacity with a
scope within the scope of an underlying
condition if I have the courage to will
the understanding I am able to
understand the Socratic principle I'm
able to say learn the you know Plato's
doctrine or something along those lines
to learn what sit within myself but if I
don't have the condition if that hasn't
been that's not coming from me and he
has to be given to me from something
else
all my willing is of no avail
so again we have a condition where faith
is something that is actually a gift
coming from the teacher to the disciple
and allowing the disciple to be in what
you might call the productive happy
proper relationship to the teacher so
let's go on from here he says the
teacher dies eventually now that he's
dead what will the learner who had been
as contemporary do maybe he sketched
some portraits of them he may even have
in his possession an entire series of
such portraits depicting and accurately
reflecting every change that by reason
of age or state of mind might have taken
place and the outward appearance of the
teacher is that is that person a
disciple he says no he's not by no means
that's not what it means to understand
though the teacher so he says how does
the learner then become a believer a
disciple when the reason is set aside
and he receives the condition when does
he receive this condition in the moment
what does this condition condition the
understanding of the eternal but such a
condition must be an eternal condition
if it's an understanding of the eternal
right he receives accordingly the
eternal condition in the moment so again
eternity and time interpenetrate one
another and he is aware that he has so
received it for otherwise he merely
comes to himself in the consciousness
that he had it from eternity which is
the Socratic point of view it is in the
moment that he receives it and from the
teacher himself all Romancing and
trumpeting abroad about one's cleverness
and penetrating the gods in canítö
though without receiving the condition
from the teacher that one took notice of
him Kierkegaard says that's all be yes
this is what he calls silly twaddle by
which one does not become a disciple but
only makes a mockery of God the servant
figure was not in disguise
and when when they says in the strength
of is of nimpah 10 resolve which is like
his love the God makes himself the equal
of the humblest let no innkeeper
professor of philosophy at mansion each
is shrewd enough fellow to detect
anything unless God gives the condition
for being able to detect this now what
does it mean again let's think about
this for a moment
reason was set aside so that faith could
enter in does that mean that reason is
now like set aside forever no that means
that reason he has a role to play in
here this is something that Kierkegaard
is not they think
adequately sketched out in part because
he was reacting so strongly against the
rationalism of his day which thought
that the learner could you know by
virtue of using their reason to sort of
you know attain to this Hegel would be
an example but some others would as well
so let's go on from here
he says the disciple knows that he would
have seen nothing without the condition
why because the first thing he learned
to understand was that he was in error
so the first thing the disciple received
was learning I can't be the judge of
everything I actually need to receive
something because I am impoverished when
it comes to that so he says in that case
is not faith as paradoxical as the
paradox that's important again in
philosophy of religion very often people
want to and also actually a lot of
people in theology they want to have a
definition of faith they want to nail
faith down a lot of religious people do
too they'll say you know they'll quote
this this passage by it by Paul you know
and say well there you go that's faith
or they don't quote some three from
schleiermacher or something from Tillich
or something from you know whoever the
flavor of the month is as far as
theology goes and Kierkegaard is saying
hey that's not going to cut it that's
not going to work
any formula in which you're going to try
to compress and and
channel in and exhaust faith is actually
gonna lose sense of what faith is
because faith is the relationship to the
paradox and it becomes through that
paradoxical that means that ironically
you know faith is supposed to be belief
right it goes against ordinary belief so
that requires a transformation of so it
says faith itself is a miracle all that
holds true the paradox also holds true
faith then the framework of this miracle
everything is again Socratic yet so that
the miracles never cancel the miracle
namely that the eternal condition is
given in time everything is Socratic the
relationship between one contemporary
and another insofar as both they're
believers is entirely Socratic they can
learn from each other now right he's
talking about a community of believers
at this point the one knows the other
nothing but both Oh everything to the
God so what is this doing this is
encompassing the Socratic relation into
this reason is not set aside you still
need that in order to engage with other
believers the trouble will come in when
things just evolve to this level and
faith gets gets taken out of the picture
so now this is really interested again
he brings in a interlocutor and the
interlocutor says then it seems the
contemporary derives absolutely no
advantage from his contemporanea
contemporary vanity and yet if we assume
that you have what you've assumed about
God's appearance among men it lies so
near at hand that the contemporary
generation is blessed because it's on it
heard and Kierkegaard says yeah that's
that's it
the contemporary disciple meaning the
contemporary at that given point in time
when there is some sort of you know
divine manifestation you know God
becoming
becoming human they're no better off
than the disciple 2,000 years later as
far as all of this goes Kierkegaard says
yes that's exactly it so he says if
we're looking at this in terms of for
example a festivity he says suppose that
an emperor celebrated his marriage for
an entire week with festivities the like
of which had never been been seen and he
give some description of this right let
us assume that it all happened in the
past we had to be content with the
meager and fall through fasting report
of what had taken place why should we
not humanly speaking count the
contemporaries happy that is to say that
contemporaries who saw and heard and
grasped with their hands people
sometimes think about religious life
like this you know and if you if you
think about the Gospels for example
think about how little is actually
chronicled in those Gospels even of the
the period of ministry you know three
roughly three year period how few
accounts are actually given how much
telescoping there is you know this is
kind of a side note but this will this
will bring a lot of things home I
remember and it's now almost yeah it's
about ten years I think since the
Passion of the Christ came out Mel
Gibson's movie where a lot of people got
quite upset because you know these these
scenes were the scourging and the
torturing is going on or those are
pretty horrific and I remember you know
people saying wow you know I never
really I never really got it that he
endured so much than other people will
let you know saying yeah they shouldn't
be showing that sort of thing and my
reaction was you know well when you read
the Gospels what the hell did you think
it meant when they said and then they
scourge dim what do you think scourgings
were like
but the only reason I knew that was
because you know I know some historical
things because I do a lot of you know
historical work so I know that people
were you know quick brutal and that at
punishments were you know they went on
for a while and they didn't let up - too
easy now he's talking about something
like that wouldn't have been better to
be there with say Christ and know
exactly what what was going on
wouldn't you be better off as a disciple
that wouldn't you know wouldn't you have
more resources and he says suppose the
splendor had been of a different kind
not immediately apparent to the senses
what profit would there be with their
what profit would there then be and
being a contemporary since one would not
on that account necessarily be
contemporary with the splendor notice
what he says there you can peek you can
be contemporary with some events and
yeah yet not be a contemporary of those
events because you're missing what's
going on in them you're missing the
significance you know great examples
have him movie terms as this guy Forrest
Gump right you see him just go wandering
around he's in the world historical
moments and doesn't realize the
significance of what he's evolved and
then later on as is telling this story
along with this you know box of
chocolates to this lady who's sitting
there listening to him and you get the
sense he still doesn't understand the
significance of it well a lot of people
you know who were they're present at the
time of this religious teacher would be
in that sort of circumstance
so Kierkegaard says what does it mean
then to say that one can be a
contemporary without being contemporary
that one may be a contemporary and
through utilizing this advantage yet not
be a contemporary what does this mean
except that it's quite impossible to be
an immediate contemporary of such a
teacher and of such an event
so the real contemporary
he says is not the real contemporary by
virtue of immediate contempt
contemporanea contemporaneity
well it's a tough word to say but by
virtue of something else so it's not
being in that time in place you know how
to look to that teacher listening to his
every word that makes the person the
contemporary disciple that gives them
the advantage you might say so he says a
contemporary may be for all that in on
contemporary the real contemporary is
not such by virtue of his immediate
contemporaneity ergo it must also be
possible for a non contemporary to be a
contemporary by virtue of something
which makes the contemporary a real
contemporary so what would that be what
would it be that could place us in close
a communion in close of an intimate
personal relationship that the Stowe is
not only faith but also renews reason to
the teacher now in this present moment
just as much now as it did in character
it's time just as much in pure congratz
time as it did in 30 ad well he's going
to give you the the reply to that what
is that condition that condition is
faith so he says the immediate Canton
contemporaneity can serve only as an
occasion a conservators an occasion for
the acquirement of historical knowledge
it can serve as an occasion for the
contemporary to acquire Socratic
deepening of his self-knowledge finally
it may serve as an occasion by which the
contemporary is one who is in error
receives the condition from the God and
soul beholds his glory with the eyes of
faith but such a contemporary says is
not in the immediate sense of
witness he is contemporary as a believer
in the autopsy of faith but in the spot
top see and this is a beautiful thing
that he says here in this autopsy every
non contemporary in the immediate sense
everybody who has divorced from from the
what they call the christ event by
time-space you know even language I mean
think about the Gospels are written in
Greek they retained in that Greek
naswinger the Aramaic that these guys
are speaking a lot of the time there's
you know especially Gospel mark you know
there's a few Aramaic words but for the
most part we're distanced from it does
that mean that we can't actually be
contemporaries he says no through faith
we actually do become contemporaries if
then some member of a later generation
yearns to be a contemporary of the
immediate sense through romanticism he
only proves himself a pretender if such
a man continues to romance about how
splendid it is to be a contemporary you
know like off only I could go to a time
machine and go back and like hear those
words or you know only I could go to
Israel and like walk the path or
something like that you know unless you
actually have faith Kierkegaard says
that's not going to do you any good
you're just accumulating historical
knowledge you're not actually bringing
the historical and the eternal together
so it says this person does not go off
to meet the paradox with its law on fear
but rather trips off like a dancing
master to be on time for the Emperor's
nuptials and though he gives his
expedition a sacred name preaching
fellowship for others that they join the
pilgrimage and crowds he will
nonetheless scarcely discover the Holy
Land since it's not to be found on the
map or on the earth so he says in only
one respect could I be tempted to count
a contemporary in the immediate sense
more fortunate than the member of some
later generation the rest of us if we
assume that the century is intervening
between this event and the period of a
succeeding generation
there will presumably have accumulated
much gossip about the thing much
speculation much foolish chatter not the
untrue and confusing rumors with which
the contemporary had to contend did not
prove nearly so serious an obstacle to
the realization of a right relationship
and that's so much the more since the
echo of the century is like the echo and
some of our churches would not only
attend it to surround faith with noisy
chatter but might even have transformed
faith into chatter which could not very
well have happened in the first
generation when faith must have revealed
itself in all its pristine vigour so
here I was saying yeah I mean the
immediate disciples at least have one
bit of advantage there was so much less
bs being chattered about about this
whole relationship and about you know
who this is
God engaging as a teacher through love
through bestowing of faith through
connecting to the disciple through
actually assuming human form and and
walking breathing eating suffering dying
they at least could you know didn't have
to contend us so much chitchat about it
but even that I mean there were people
who were like yeah I think I know
exactly what this guy is he's a prophet
no he's the Messiah in this sense no
he's just the carpenter's son no and
people kept doing that here's the bottom
line essentially for this chapter the
contemporary disciple is not the person
who's contemporary in time but rather
the person who is contemporary through
this relationship which is bestowed by
God upon the learner who finds out that
he or she is actually in error that
accepts that doesn't push it away even
though it's painful even though it's
humiliating and then it takes what they
need in order to also start you know
growing in in a relationship that
overcomes that error and
somehow connects up reason and faith in
this happy passions understanding to the
paradox and reason to grow their
relationship with the largely unknown
God so that's where we'll leave off with
this one the next thing that we have to
go into is a little interlude and then
we have chapter 5 the disciple at second
hand where we're going to look at some
more of these problematics where we're
getting very close to the end of these
philosophical fragments so again what
we've seen is Kierkegaard again taking
something that is coming as a gift from
God through faith but then using reason
and it's categories to try to make sense
out of this entire relationship so we
see that Kierkegaard is not rejecting
reason at all he's actually trying to
find its proper use to fully understand
the human condition